[Music]
how's this show feeling it's been such a
great experience working with these real
guys the hero that accomplishes a
mission and or an impossible tasks
somewhat misunderstood and the guys that
work on our show that have given us
their stories to betray and get right I
think for us it's really about the
preciousness of the moments and allowing
us to explore that and really see them
kind of dive into the life outside of
their work yeah with their families how
they struggle with that how they
struggle fitting into society that's
what we want to shed the light on
sniper overwatch anyone got a shot
instead look again it's nothing there
way in when you do look at your you know
your career and it's just been like
monster after monster after monster
after monster we only you were gonna be
back after bones not this quick with
another a monster but we all knew it was
it was going to happen what do you
attribute that to like are you just
really good at making choices are you
like have you figured it out I've been
blessed for the people that I've been
I've surrounded myself with I think it's
most importantly the showrunners the
writers and the people behind it I've
done some pretty horrific independent
movies you're not always gonna be right
but I've been blessed to find some
pretty good gems this whole time because
you have one tool that you use for every
job that charge you will put on the
interior of that door would have
collapsed the entire time we were both
much younger when you were doing a lot
of physical stuff in like Buffy and
Angel a now that you're doing a lot of
physical stuff now what's the recovery
time physically for you cuz physically
you have to look like the guy in there
you know yeah you have to act like the
guy but you have to also look like the
guy yes it's pretty hard I mean my
shoulders been out for a while the knees
are the joint syrup and pain but I do
play as much hockey as I can I trained
with two NHL players they were able to
kind of transform my game along with my
son's game and I use that as my backdrop
yeah having fun in training rather than
the military aspect of training I expect
once we're engaged the Green Berets at
Sinjar will respond to our tic otherwise
if they don't pretty sure we'll be
overrun if you get a day off where you
don't have to worry about working out or
what you eat or whatever what is your
day off like the amount equipment that
you wear is just shedding and the amount
of reps you do take after take when you
are in a mission or an OP depending upon
what it is can be excruciating I just
Seminole organic kind of food guy I mean
I don't I I stick to
I don't know milk cheese and eggs I
don't really have the LA diet guys make
sure you know I don't do yoga in between
my snacks I love pizza I love Italian
food you know love ice cream
so I just kind of keep real